qui merci jean noël moi je dois vous
parler de l'aide publique au
développement parce que dans un contexte
pareil il faut pas oublier que la france
est très généreuse que l'europe est très
généreuse et que l'europe à elle seule
fournie 55 % de l'aide au développement
mondial ça veut dire que nous n'avons
pas déjà dans un premier temps de leçon
de générosité à recevoir et on peut se
demander d'ailleurs dans un tel contexte
comment se servir de cette aide publique
au développement pour contribuer à
réduire la crise actuelle ça ce serait
la première chose et puis ensuite je
voudrais vous dire pourquoi il ya aussi
des raisons d'espérer parce que les
républicains évidemment nous devons
faire face à une crise évidemment nous
devons être tout à fait ferme mais en
même temps nous devons aussi répondre à
notre tradition des do développement des
pays du sud dans un premier temps
puisque nous avons cette aide publique
au développement
ces 10 milliards d'euros par an qui sont
payés par la france d'une manière
directe ou indirecte pour venir en aide
aux pays en voie de développement sur
ces sommes 55 % sont consacrés à
l'afrique
alors on sait bien que le sujet de ce
matin c'est beaucoup le droit d'asile
mais c'est aussi mon cher eric le sujet
de fond de l'immigration et donc il faut
que nous apportions aussi des réponses à
ce sujet de fond qui va durer très
longtemps à court terme
moi je propose que l'aide publique au
développement soient conditionnées à
l'aide des états qui la reçoivent en
terme de retour dans le pays d'origine
il n'y a pas de raison puisque le droit
d'asile puisque le droit d'asile est
complètement détourné et que nous avons
sur notre sol un certain nombre
d'immigrés clandestins pour des raisons
économiques qui ne sont pas au fond des
demandeurs d'asile
il n'y a pas de raison que nous
continuons à payer l'aide publique au
développement aux pays d'où ils viennent
si nous n'avons pas des aides des
gouvernements en question pour l'aide de
retour donc la conditionnalité de l'aide
publique au développement
peut être une première solution j'ajoute
immédiatement parce que je ne voudrais
pas me faire mal comprendre de la part
des spécialistes
que dans l'aide publique au
développement il ya énormément de choses
c'est très compliqué ma proposition ne
concerne évidemment cher eric que l'aide
publique au développement en direction
des états évidemment il ne s'agit pas de
l'aide publique au développement
sur toutes les politiques qui sont mises
en oeuvre pour atteindre les objectifs
du millénaire pour le développement on
parle pas là de de l'aide pour eux la
lutte contre le sida on parle pas de
l'aide pour l'envoi des enfants dans les
écoles je ne parle évidemment que l'aide
entre états c'est très important de bien
préciser ça dans notre proposition
puisque les républicains doivent être
équilibrés on doit évidemment mettre de
la conditionnalité sur l'aide aux états
mais pas sur l'aide que nous apportons
pour toutes les actions en direction du
développement des populations
les populations ne doivent pas être
otage des éventuelles mauvaises
politiques qui sont conduites par leurs
états respectifs je crois que c'est
particulièrement important car toute la
communauté de l'aide publique au
développement ne comprendrait pas une
position qu'il serait pas dans la
tradition française et dans la stricte
de la tradition de la république crois
que c'est vraiment fondamental de le
préciser
et puis deuxième chose mes chers amis on
a aussi des raisons d'espérer
parce que il n'y aura pas d' europe
prospère dans l'avenir si nous trouvons
pas une solution avec l'afrique
55 % de notre aide va en direction de
l'afrique l'immigration le vrai sujet
c'est l'afrique et donc on a deux
problèmes à mon avis sur le très long
terme a essayé de traiter c'est très
ambitieux la première chose c'est
comment est ce qu'on peut faire du
développement économique en afrique
puisque seul le développement économique
en afrique pourra permettre un
ralentissement de l'immigration et donc
moi je suggère c'est ma deuxième
proposition que l'aide publique au
développement française soit concentrée
sur les opérations de développement
économiques qui sont créatrices
d'emplois en afrique qui donc permettre
de donner de l'emploi à toutes les
populations qui en attendent quand
j'étais quand j'avais l'honneur d'être
dans le gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy
je vous signale au passage quand même et
là dessus la gauche n'a pas de leçons à
nous donner puisque en cinq ans nous
avons fait passer l'aide publique au
développement de 0,36 de notre budget
n'est ce pas j'ai repris ce à plus de 0
40 et depuis que les socialistes sont là
à nouveau les publique au développement
est en pleine régression
donc ils nous font des leçons mais dans
le budget on voit pas là où ils sont
efficaces
donc c'est à nous d'assumer ce
développement économique
et puis enfin je pense que dans les
politiques de développement
il ya certaines initiatives qui sont
prises dans les pays d'afrique
concernant notamment le planning
familial tout à l'heure brice a
justement rappelé les grandes évolutions
de la population
tout ce que l'on dit tout ce que l'on
met en place aussi bien pour la lutte
sur l'immigration clandestine que pour
l'immigration en général tous les
efforts que nous pourrons faire seront
complètement balayées
si effectivement l'afrique passe de 1
milliard à 2 milliards d'habitants dans
les 50 ans à venir ou dans les quarante
ans à venir
donc moi je propose que dans notre aide
publique au développement puisqu'il ya
déjà certains embryon de politique on
soutiennent vraiment massivement c'est
un sujet très délicat qu'on ne peut pas
prendre à bâle corps à bras le corps à
la place des autres états mais que l'on
soutienne vraiment très fortement les
politique de planning familial qui sont
mises en oeuvre dans les états africains
ainsi nous pourrions agir sur les deux
choses développement économique création
de deux emplois au sud de la
méditerranée est hantée tenté de faire
ce qui est possible de faire pour
minimiser l'évolution de la population
sur le continent africain d'ici à 2050
quelques grandes orientations qui
pourraient être prises mais à court
terme pour contribuer à la gestion de la
crise conditionnalité conditionner leur
aide publique au développement des zéros
auprès des états à l'aide au retour là
ce que je veux dire sur le sujet
si allah